fox news found a good thing they they
can make fun of liberals and they are
doing it to great success we will
discuss why in a minute but in the
meantime i just want to tell you fox
news smells a good thing so they are
coming up with they have greenlit a
whole new slate of conservative
television shows would you like to see
some of the things they have coming on
um
i know you would
uh like a third rock from the sun
according to science
uh
one of their new ones comedians in cars
getting jerky is going to be
uh i love ducey
myth trusters
[Applause]
how i met your handmaid
uh
mad about jews with steve bannon
[Applause]
accuse the boss
i dream of gerrymandering
curb your environmentalism
[Applause]
and this is gus
so okay
all right
so now you're gonna like this part
i've been asked over the years many
times why isn't there conservative
comedy
and i always would give the answer which
i think was the true answer there's
there's not good fodder for it you know
the liberals aren't crazy
this was
my answer for many years i i cited
dennis miller who is a great comedian
period as a community he's great but
when he became a conservative he was
tasked with like doing 10 minutes on
nancy pelosi
she's in the same way we would talk
about sarah palin but nancy pelosi isn't
funny like that because she's not crazy
or stupid
sarah palin is a it's easy to
she is and it's easy to make fun of her
really
it's easy to make fun of
wasilla living
meth lab whatever sarah palin i'm not
saying she works in the meth lab but i'm
sure we did some jokes about that um
well the family
so there was this this
there was nothing to make fun of that
was that crazy
now
i don't think it's the same situation i
keep saying to the liberals you know
what if what you're doing sounds like an
onion headline
stop
and that's why
this is why there is an opening
for conservative comedy because you know
when you when you tear down statues of
abraham lincoln
in the land of lincoln
land of lincoln cancels lincoln it's an
onion headline you know three-year-olds
pick their own gender is an onion
headline
you know a lot of this stuff that goes
on on the left now it's you know seattle
votes to decriminalize crime
now
the problem is that
they don't know how to do comedy
but if they found someone who did they
could
because i do it more here than i used to
because comedy goes where the funny is
and there is funny on the left now as
well as the right
you